hi
how are you
i am well thank you for talking to me
about this i
love this show on two levels i get the
nostalgia factor for reading the books
from when i was younger and it also
proves that good stories and good
characters are universal no matter your
age so
what has it meant to you guys to get to
be a part of the babysitter's club
what's the coolest thing about
being a part of this world and doing
this show
i mean it's such an iconic series that
we're all able to um portray and i feel
like we're all related to our characters
in some way i mean that's the most
magical part about the babysitter's club
is that everything is so relatable
whether that's the situations the
characters um the things that we all get
to do together or as individuals um it's
just it's such an inspiring piece and
it's so empowering as young women
entrepreneurs going through this
business but also our personal lives as
well um it's
it's a dream come true and i still can't
believe to this day that's not just a
home movie that i made with my best
friends it's you know it's out there
it's on netflix that's insane so i think
it's just a grateful experience overall
just just being with the girls and and
doing what i love it's like
i don't know it's indescribable i swear
it it's it's like a dream come true
it's it's like all the hard work of of
chasing your dream it finally pays off
and you're you're on the set with these
these wonderful people surrounding you
and it's just like a really big group
hug it's really nice
definitely getting to do what you love
with the people you love is truly a
dream come true
um playing dawn is
really great because we have so many
similarities and also getting to portray
a character that um kids can relate to
and find similarities and this goes for
all of the characters also playing dawn
as a latina girl
when i grew up i didn't have too many
people on screen that i could have
looked up to and so i think it's really
special that i get to be that person
that i never really had to look up to um
and i hope that i'm an inspiration to
others and um and i hope that i spread a
message that if i can do it you can do
it
enter what was it like for you to join
the show and take on this role what were
you most nervous about and what made you
feel most reassured once you got on set
everyone was super supportive and kind i
remember the first scene
you know doing something new can always
be a little scary but with the help of
your friend you can always get through
it um and
it was just wonderful really connecting
with all the girls we built a wonderful
relationship and
yeah it's truly been a dream filming
so what's it like to play the leader of
this group is that a role that you fit
into naturally what sort of leader would
you say she is in season two
well just like christy i'm also
extremely independent and
uh but christy chrissy really is a
natural leader she she knows how to work
with people and she knows how to get
what she wants and also compromise
she is assertive and she is
punctual she's just really admirable in
the sense that she knows who she is and
she knows what she wants
malia what's it like for you with your
character you know things are changing a
little bit with her family what is it
like for her how does she feel about
what's going on with that situation
yeah marianne i mean she turned on one
of these stepsisters so much it's crazy
we go to such lengths and such extents
to becoming stepsisters and there's
always that tease of is it finally going
to happen are they going to announce
what they just proposed or
is it something else then this one a
case is it something like that and i get
to see that throughout the second season
and throughout john's night's episodes
in particular i think that's really fun
to be able to portray um but the course
of the first season marianne has a huge
arc and throughout the second season we
just see it progress even farther um so
i'm most excited for you guys to see
that sense of relatability and for um
those awkward moments because you know
this is middle school there's going to
be awkward moments there's going to be
moments where it's so cringy that you
want to hide yourself um so just having
that kind of comfort show for people to
watch and um just going back to lean on
it because at the end of the day we get
through it as a team and i think that's
the most
magical part
yeah kendra your characters definitely
have some sisterly disagreements but how
would you say that brings them closer
together once they work through that
um i have a strong feeling that you know
con whenever um friends go through
conflict and they you know figure it out
and they get through it that just shows
uh how strong of a friendship that they
really have and how strong of a bond
they have and i think it's really
important that um marianne and don you
know get through all of the conflicts
that they have and you know at the end
of the day that just makes them
stronger
together so your character has some ups
and downs this season and while christy
has a family moment in the last episode
that just broke my heart she then also
has a very happy moment that kind of
makes up for that so what did you most
enjoy about her journey this season and
where she ends up especially when it
comes to her family
well i can't give it any spoilers but i
think christie ends right where she
belongs and right where she always kind
of
needed to
be yeah that's why i was trying to be
vague and talk about it emotionally
because she definitely
it's very definitely highs and lows
yes oh absolutely it's it's such a hard
time for her and then it's such a sweet
moment it's it's a lot going on but i'm
happy for christy
are there things that you guys still
have on your own personal wishlist for
your character things that you're hoping
to still get to do or explore with them
in future seasons
i mean there's over a hundred books so i
feel like there's so much room to play
with them the writers have done an
amazing job in the first two seasons um
so who knows what will happen with the
third or the fourth or the fifth
whatever seasons there are um i mean i
wish i could go go on for years but bsc
will forever be something that i hold
close to my heart
but if you really ask i would love to
have a cat in the next season
there's something about that tigger um
that marianne has in the books i would
just be so immensely grateful if i could
just play with a kid in my free time so
that's all i say it's a bit answer done
i second to this with having marianne um
if marianne has a cat you know marianne
is mostly with dawn and so
you know dawn loves animals she loves
the environment
definitely be a fun time playing with
the cat with marianne um i would also
say
don if you've seen season one you know
that dawn's parents are divorced and i
would love to see her father and her
brother
come and visit her from california and
spend some time with her because i know
that she struggles and she definitely
misses them
many times
uh for me well i third
malia's cat thing because
who doesn't want a cat on set i love
animals you know
but
for christy personally i think it would
be really cool to include christy's
crushers
in the next upcoming potential seasons
what did you guys must enjoy just about
getting to work with each other learning
from such different such a different
diverse group of
girls
uh
working with the girls is the best like
honestly they're just they're the best
girls you're ever gonna meet they're all
so strong and they're so unique and
it's just really cool to watch us all
grow together
100 yeah exactly what sophie said i mean
like you said this is a group of young
diverse um entrepreneurial young girls
that are going through a business
struggle but are also going through
struggles in their own teenage lives um
this is something that's super relatable
and with marianne and now being that
bipod character that people are able to
look up to uh it's just so inspirational
aspirational because i didn't have that
person that i was able to look up to
growing up
especially with curly hair that one is
the most important thing for me you know
with throughout the first season we see
her um with her braids for the first
four episodes and then she finally lets
it down and we're able to see her
struggles um there was this one team
meeting that i got to include a head
wrap scarf which i usually wear to bed
and i got to include my own while i was
on set just to be it more accurate for
young girls that have curly hair
especially black hair
it was just so amazing to be able to
incorporate those moments because you
can't be what you can't see and i think
that just stands for whatever we do in
this club it's um just so relatable like
i've been saying multiple times now um
but yeah
kendra take it away
um yes definitely um
i think that each of the girls struggle
with something
but they always overcome it and i also
think that it's really important
for people to find similarities and even
differences
in each of the girls everyone is so
empowering
and confident in who they are and that
is also a really important message to
spread all around to kids and people of
all ages to not be afraid to be yourself
and to do whatever you want to do and be
whoever you want to be no matter what
anyone thinks of you
thank you guys so much for talking to me
you're all so perfect in your characters
so thank you
thank you